This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Off the east coast of mainland Canada is the island of Newfoundland. The island is as far east as you can go and still be in Canada, so far east in fact that it has its own time zone, a half an hour later than anywhere else in North America. If you've seen a photograph of the island, it's probably the one that went viral last year of a small village on the eastern coast, and the foreground are rolling hills in a couple of houses. In the background, a gigantic iceberg floats by on the choppy blue sea.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。在加拿大大陆东海岸外，坐落着纽芬兰岛。这座岛屿位于加拿大最东端，事实上，它太靠东了，以至于拥有自己独特的时区，比北美其他任何地方都要晚半小时。如果你见过这张岛屿的照片，那很可能是去年在网上疯传的那张：照片前景是起伏的丘陵和几座房屋，背景中，一座巨大的冰山漂浮在波涛汹涌的蓝色大海上。
Yeah, icebergs float by occasionally, but that one was actually scary big. And nice pronunciation of Newfoundland, by the way. A lot of people say Newfoundland, and it's a bit of a sore spot with us locals. That is Newfoundland native Luke Quinton. And I want to take us to a different part of the island, to a little town on the north eastern side called Gander. Now, looking back, I was all of 20 years old at the time, though I thought I was ancient. It's Christmas Eve, 1972, and Ian Blackmore is working.
是的，冰山偶尔会漂过，但那座冰山确实大得吓人。顺便说一句，你对“纽芬兰”（Newfoundland）的发音很地道。很多人读错这个词，这对我们当地人来说是个痛点。刚才那位是纽芬兰本地人卢克·昆顿。我想带大家去岛上的另一个地方，去东北部一个叫甘德的小镇。回想起来，当时我才20岁，虽然我那时觉得自己已经老了。那是1972年的平安夜，伊恩·布莱克莫尔正在工作。
My name is Ian Blackmore, and I was a photographer with the Gander Beacon after I finished high school before I went to college in Toronto. Ian's coworker Gerald Vokey was an editor on the same local paper. He's going to help tell this story. It was Christmas Eve and her mother was, you know, getting things ready for Santa Claus. Gerald was home that day in 1972. His family was getting ready for Christmas and he wanted to get his daughter out of the house.
我叫伊恩·布莱克莫尔，高中毕业后、去多伦多上大学之前，我曾在《甘德灯塔报》担任摄影师。伊恩的同事杰拉德·沃基是同一家当地报纸的编辑。他将协助讲述这个故事。那是平安夜，他母亲正在为圣诞老人准备东西。1972年的那天，杰拉德在家。他的家人正在准备过圣诞节，他想带女儿出去走走。
So they decided to go hang out at the local airport as you do. As you do when you live in a tiny town in Canada And the airport is the best thing around also. This is not a normal airport, but we'll get to that soon You never knew with the airport being up there who might Come through at any given time Regardless of the hour of the day or at night or whatever And when Gerald got to the gander airport, he started asking around. I asked the security there, you know, what was going on.
于是他们决定去当地机场闲逛，就像人们常做的那样。当你住在加拿大一个小镇时，你就会这么做。而且机场也是周围最好的地方。这不是一个普通的机场，但我们很快就会谈到这一点。你永远不知道在机场会遇到谁，无论白天还是黑夜。当杰拉德到达甘德机场时，他开始四处打听。我问那里的保安，到底发生了什么事。
And they said, Fidel Castro is here. And I said, what? Fidel Castro was there in the airport, and he was more or less just hanging out. I had dinner with him. Yeah, in the dining room, naturally. He had his traditional fatigues and his combat boots. Green fatigues, no medals or nothing, just playing uniform.
他们说，菲德尔·卡斯特罗在这里。我说，什么？菲德尔·卡斯特罗就在机场，他基本上只是在闲逛。我和他一起吃了晚饭。是的，就在餐厅里，很自然。他穿着传统的军装和作战靴。绿色的军装，没有勋章什么的，就是普通的制服。
Turned out Castro had a pretty long layover in Gander, so at some point, he basically says, give me a tour of your town. He wanted to see the town. So Ian and Gerald and Fidel Castro all pylons and cars and go driving around the little town until they come across a kid sledding. There's a young fella with his dog and probably another friend there and they were taking turns going down on their toboggan. Of course Mr. Castro decided that looked interesting and figured he might see what thing wasn't how it worked, not being that familiar to snow.
事实证明，卡斯特罗在甘德有很长的中转时间，所以到某个时候，他基本上说，带我参观一下你们的小镇吧。他想看看这个小镇。于是伊恩、杰拉德和菲德尔·卡斯特罗坐上车，在小镇里转悠，直到他们遇到一个正在滑雪橇的孩子。有一个小伙子带着他的狗，可能还有另一个朋友在那里，他们轮流坐着雪橇滑下去。当然，卡斯特罗先生觉得这看起来很有趣，想看看这是什么东西，它是怎么运作的，因为他对雪不太熟悉。
Castro gets on this sled and starts down the hill, and Ian Blackmore snaps a picture. I got ahead of him before he started on the slide down, so I was in position for the catch him on his way down, and well, photograph him I didn't catch him. Ian Blackmore's photograph of Fidel Castro's sledding would end up in Time magazine. And the amazing thing about this anecdote isn't how unique it was for Gander, but how totally normal. The Gander Airport was used to hosting really famous people from all over the world.
卡斯特罗坐上雪橇开始下坡，伊恩·布莱克莫尔拍了一张照片。在他开始滑下之前，我跑到了他前面，所以我处于有利位置，在他滑下来时捕捉到他，嗯，拍下了他的照片。我没能抓住他。伊恩·布莱克莫尔拍摄的菲德尔·卡斯特罗滑雪橇的照片最终登上了《时代》杂志。这个轶事最神奇的地方不在于它对甘德来说有多独特，而在于它有多么平常。甘德机场过去常常接待来自世界各地的名人。
It wasn't just some tiny airport in some tiny town. It was a very large, very important airport in some tiny town. But before we hear how this place came to be, I want to take you inside the airport because it's an incredible building. Okay, here on the Gander Airport. The Gander Airport is such a mid-century modern time capsule that I actually think I have to bring up some lounge music right now. This place is straight out of an episode of Mad Men, you know, Mad Men with Newfoundlander
它不仅仅是某个小镇里的一个小机场。它是某个小镇里一个非常大、非常重要的机场。但在我们了解这个地方是如何形成的之前，我想带你走进机场内部，因为它是一座令人难以置信的建筑。好的，这里是甘德机场。甘德机场是一个如此典型的中世纪现代时间胶囊，我真的觉得现在得放点休息室音乐了。这个地方简直就像《广告狂人》里的一集，你知道，带有纽芬兰口音的《广告狂人》。
accents. If you follow me across here, over on the apron. Jerry Cram is a commission there at the Gander Airport. The job is part fixer, part security guard. Jerry will probably be the one to give you a tour if you ask. The terrestrial floring is all from Italy. Right here is what we call the birds of welcome. Jerry is pointing at a bronze sculpture of seven birds that greets you when you walk into the lounge. The blue and the grey furniture is all from the late 50s, early 60s.
如果你跟着我走到这边，在停机坪上。杰里·克拉姆是甘德机场的专员。这份工作既是修理工，又是保安。如果你问的话，杰里很可能会带你参观。地面的地板全是从意大利进口的。就在这里，我们称之为“欢迎之鸟”。杰里指着一座青铜雕塑，那是当你走进休息室时迎接你的七只鸟。蓝色和灰色的家具都是50年代末、60年代初的风格。
The International Lounge of the Gander Airport is this big, airy space, super high ceilings, and when you walk in, you're immediately awash in the orangey glow of the 1950s. The vinyl chairs and couches are arranged in U-shaped seating areas. They were designed by famous mid-century designers like Charles and Ray Eams and Robin Bush. The Gander International Lounge has been called the single most important modernist room in Canada. Even the bathrooms are their own amazing time capsule. The women's restroom especially.
甘德机场的国际休息室是一个宽敞、通风的空间，天花板非常高，当你走进去时，你会立刻沉浸在1950年代那种橙色的光芒中。乙烯基椅子和沙发被布置成U型座位区。它们是由查尔斯和雷·伊姆斯以及罗宾·布什等著名的中世纪设计师设计的。甘德国际休息室被称为加拿大最重要的现代主义房间。甚至连洗手间也是一个令人惊叹的时间胶囊。尤其是女洗手间。
Jerry calls out a warning so that we can go in. Male bird, I don't work good to go. This is not a gross airport bathroom. It's beautiful mid century luxury. There's a row of swivel chairs in front of a counter and a wall size mirror. It has two showers because yes, people used to shower at the airport. Well, there is two showers in this room as well as the end of the men's. But now you can say you were in the washroom that the Queen Poverty knows in June the 1959. When this international lounge of the Gander Airport opened in 1959, the Queen of England herself came for the opening. And yeah, the townspeople
杰里大声发出警告，以便我们可以进去。男士止步，我还没准备好。这不是一个肮脏的机场厕所。这是美丽的中世纪奢华。柜台前有一排旋转椅和一面墙那么大的镜子。它有两个淋浴间，因为是的，人们过去常在机场洗澡。嗯，这个房间里有两个淋浴间，男士那边尽头也有。但现在你可以说你进过女王在1959年6月用过的洗手间了。当甘德机场的这个国际休息室于1959年开放时，英国女王本人亲自前来参加开幕式。是的，镇上的人们
popped knob with her too. A lot has happened in this airport, and the story of how it came to be and what it's become is really also a story about the history of air travel. By Newfoundland, because the shortest way. Clear, let me show you. You've got to look at it on a globe. If you trace a direct course from New York to Paris, you'll see that it takesander existed, Newfoundland's grassy fields were the jumping off points for transatlantic daredevil pilots.
也和她一起喝了酒。这个机场发生了很多事，关于它如何形成以及它变成了什么的故事，实际上也是航空旅行历史的故事。通过纽芬兰，因为这是最短的路径。清楚点，让我给你展示一下。你得在地球仪上看。如果你从纽约到巴黎画一条直线，你会发现它经过……在甘德存在之前，纽芬兰的草地是跨大西洋冒险飞行员的跳板。
Amelia Earhart, Alcock and Brown, Lindbergh, all of them. Because it was so far east, it made sense to start there if you were worried about getting across the Atlantic with enough fuel. Eventually, the British government, which controlled Newfoundland at the time, started to take note. Maybe there was something to this whole air travel thing. In 1936, the British chose what was then basically a patch of woods on the eastern side of Newfoundland as the site for over a million square yards of runways.
阿梅莉亚·埃尔哈特、阿尔科克和布朗、林德伯格，他们所有人。因为它位于最东端，如果你担心带着足够的燃料飞越大西洋，从那里出发是有道理的。最终，当时控制纽芬兰的英国政府开始注意到这一点。也许航空旅行这件事真的有搞头。1936年，英国人选择了当时基本上是纽芬兰东部一片树林的地方，作为超过一百万平方码跑道的选址。
By the spring of 1938, the Gander Airport was fully operational, but the massive runways were mostly unused. There just weren't enough planes in operation that could actually survive the crossing of the Atlantic Ocean. It was a very, very risky journey. In the two decades before the war, only 100 planes had crossed the Atlantic. 50 others had tried and failed. 40 people had died.
到1938年春天，甘德机场已全面投入运营，但巨大的跑道大多处于闲置状态。当时运营的飞机根本不足以真正完成跨越大西洋的飞行。那是一次非常、非常冒险的旅程。在战争前的二十年里，只有100架飞机飞越大西洋。另有50架尝试过但失败了。40人丧生。
Then in 1939, World War II began in Europe, and Allied forces wanted as many fighter planes as they could get their hands on. Americans and Canadians had been shipping planes over by boat, but that wasn't working out so well. They were being torpedoed by the German submarine and whatnot, so they were losing more airplanes than they were actually making it over to the UK. That's a story in Informer Air Dispatcher, Dean Call, and he says to get planes to the UK, the British had to come up with a new idea. They would have to put up what we call a bladder inside. It was a spare fuel tank, basically, to give new idea. The process of flying the planes from Gander to Scotland began in 1940 and was called the ferry command.
然后是1939年，第二次世界大战在欧洲爆发，盟军想要尽可能多地获得战斗机。美国人和加拿大人一直通过船只运送飞机，但效果并不好。它们被德国潜艇击沉了，所以他们损失的飞机比真正到达英国的还要多。这是前空中调度员迪恩·卡尔的故事，他说为了把飞机送到英国，英国人必须想出一个新主意。他们必须在内部安装我们所说的气囊。这基本上是一个备用油箱，用来提供新主意。将飞机从甘德飞往苏格兰的过程始于1940年，被称为“渡轮司令部”。
The first crossing was seven planes and it took place on a freezing night in November. The pilots had to fly in the dark because lights could alert the Germans. Miraculously, all seven made it. But that was just the first day. Over the course of the war, 20,000 planes were brought to Gander to be flown across the Atlantic for the war. Some days there would be 100 airplanes that would go over. The Churchill was even quoted at one point. He referred to Gander as the largest aircraft carrier in the North Atlantic.
第一次跨越是七架飞机，发生在11月一个寒冷的夜晚。飞行员必须在黑暗中飞行，因为灯光可能会惊动德国人。奇迹般的是，所有七架飞机都成功了。但这只是第一天。在战争期间，有20,000架飞机被带到甘德，飞越大西洋参加战争。有些日子会有100架飞机飞过。丘吉尔甚至在某个时候被引用过。他称甘德为北大西洋最大的航空母舰。
I guess it was the turning point of the war really for Britain. Gander was making history, even though at the time there was no actual town of Gander. There was no town, so there were people living between intersections and runways. And that's where the Americans and the Canadians and the British had built wartime buildings. Frank DeBoe was a former air traffic controller at Gander and his story into the airport. And he says the early town of Gander was basically just a few living quarters right next to the runways. I would say, you know, a hundred yards or even closer than that.
我想这确实是英国战争的转折点。甘德正在创造历史，尽管当时并没有真正的甘德镇。没有城镇，所以人们住在交叉路口和跑道之间。那就是美国人、加拿大人和英国人建造战时建筑的地方。弗兰克·德博是甘德的前空中交通管制员，他的故事进入了机场。他说早期的甘德镇基本上只是跑道旁边的一些生活区。我会说，你知道，一百码甚至更近。
And they made a hell of a lot of noise. Those aircraft. Because the Gander airport started as a military operation, it wasn't until the war was over and civilian air travel began that they decided to build a separate town away from the runways. And then in the late 1950s, the Canadian government built that fancy international lounge at the airport. In 1958, just a year before the new lounge opened, jets like the De Havelin Comet and the DC-8
而且它们发出了巨大的噪音。那些飞机。因为甘德机场最初是一项军事行动，直到战争结束、民用航空旅行开始，他们才决定在远离跑道的地方建立一个独立的城镇。然后在1950年代末，加拿大政府在机场建造了那个豪华的国际休息室。1958年，就在新休息室开放的前一年，像德哈维兰彗星和DC-8这样的喷气式飞机
were introduced. These planes could make the long track across the Atlantic without having to stop and refuel in Gander. But they took a while to go mainstream, and for years, Gander served as a stopping place for international travel. These were the glory days of Gander. When celebrities from all over the world would wind up stopping through on their way to or from the states, the Beatles first step in North America wasn't in New York, it was in Gander, Newfoundland. The Gander Airport became by far the hottest place to be in Gander. Oh yeah, used to go up and hang around up there and watch the people coming in on the
被引入。这些飞机可以在不需在甘德停留加油的情况下完成跨越大西洋的长途飞行。但它们花了很长时间才成为主流，多年来，甘德一直是国际旅行的停靠站。这是甘德的黄金时代。来自世界各地的名人在往返美国的途中都会在这里停留，披头士乐队在北美的第一步不是在纽约，而是在纽芬兰的甘德。甘德机场成为了甘德最热门的地方。哦，是的，过去常去那里闲逛，看着人们从
planes and, you know, who's there and right on the escalator. It was a hotspot for fun. John Beard grew up in Gander. You know, everything revolved around the airport. I mean, that was one industry town. It was a lot quieter place now than it was then. In the 1960s, air travel was still pretty exclusive. A lot of North American tourists still traveled to Europe by ship.
飞机上下来，你知道，谁在那里，就在自动扶梯上。那是一个充满乐趣的热点。约翰·比尔德在甘德长大。你知道，一切都围绕着机场。我的意思是，那是一个单一产业城镇。现在比那时安静多了。在1960年代，航空旅行仍然相当昂贵。许多北美游客仍然乘船前往欧洲。
But celebrities and heads of state from all over the world were paying big bucks to fly, and many of them were stopping in Gander in that beautiful mid-century modern lounge. A lot of famous people who came through the Gander Airport tried to go unnoticed, but some really wanted a cocktail from the bar, and if they were in the airport bar, they probably were interacting with the people of Gander. Security was pretty loose back then, to say the least. I met Marilyn Roll. Was that like, like, a bad dude again.
但来自世界各地的名人和国家元首支付高昂的费用飞行，他们中的许多人在甘德那个美丽的中世纪现代休息室停留。许多经过甘德机场的名人试图不被注意，但有些人确实想在酒吧喝杯鸡尾酒，如果他们在机场酒吧，他们很可能在与甘德的人们互动。当时的安保相当松懈，至少可以这么说。我遇到了玛丽莲·梦露。那就像，像，一个坏家伙。
Bob Hope and Kings and Queens of various countries, King of Jordan, King of Saudi Arabia, Mikhail Gorvatrov. My Choman Randy Savage. I met President Bush. That's the former mayor of Gander, Claude Elliott. I met the Queen of England, I flew with Prince Philip on his chopper. The locals also love to tell a story about Frank Sinatra trying to cut in line at the airport bar.
鲍勃·霍普，还有各个国家的国王和王后，约旦国王，沙特阿拉伯国王，米哈伊尔·戈尔巴乔夫。还有兰迪·萨维奇。我遇到了布什总统。那是甘德前市长克劳德·埃利奥特。我遇到了英国女王，我和菲利普亲王一起坐过他的直升机。当地人也喜欢讲一个关于弗兰克·辛纳屈试图在机场酒吧插队的故事。
I'm getting told to go to the back. But as time went on, the lounge wasn't just a scene of people drinking cocktails on their way to London. By the late 1960s, most commercial jets could make it across the Atlantic without needing to refuel, but Gander was still serving an important role in international travel, especially to communist countries who couldn't fly to the US or use its airspace. Gander was the major stopping point between Moscow and Havana, but this occasionally invited defectors seeking asylum in Canada.
我被告知要排到后面去。但随着时间的推移，休息室不仅仅是人们在去伦敦途中喝鸡尾酒的场景。到1960年代末，大多数商用喷气式飞机可以在不需要加油的情况下飞越大西洋，但甘德在国际旅行中仍然发挥着重要作用，特别是对于那些不能飞往美国或使用其领空的共产主义国家。甘德是莫斯科和哈瓦那之间的主要停靠点，但这偶尔会引来寻求在加拿大避难的叛逃者。
And in particular, there was a fair number from Cuba. That's Gary Voki, Gerald Voki's son, and he says sometimes people would get off their plane coming from Cuba or Bulgaria or some other communist country in Seekas Island. Not that this was easy. Vokey remembers witnessing one incident in particular in which a woman from a Cuban flight attempted to escape down the lounge escalator to Canadian authorities while the Cuban flight crew tried to stop her. They had the lady hold by her feet.
特别是，有相当多的人来自古巴。那是加里·沃基，杰拉德·沃基的儿子，他说有时人们会从古巴、保加利亚或其他共产主义国家飞来的飞机上下来，寻求庇护。这并不容易。沃基记得目睹了一起特别的事件，一名来自古巴航班的妇女试图逃下休息室的自动扶梯向加拿大当局求助，而古巴机组人员试图阻止她。他们抓住那个女人的脚。
The Canadians had her hold by her head and her arms. So she was upside down, going up the escalator. And she had a dress on her dress was back over her head. It nearly turned violent. And it was for me, even as a kid, it was one of the most iconic things I've ever seen. For residents of Gander, life was also about living alongside people from all over the
加拿大人抓住她的头和手臂。所以她是倒挂着，上了自动扶梯。她穿着裙子，裙子翻到了头上。这差点演变成暴力事件。对我来说，即使作为一个孩子，这也是我见过的最标志性的事情之一。对于甘德的居民来说，生活也意味着与来自世界各地为航空公司工作的人们一起生活。
world who worked for the airlines. Arrow Flot, the Russian airliner, had over 150 crew and flight planners in Gander alone. Gander, in its day, was a lot more multicultural than probably some of the bigger cities in Canada. The Brits had people, the Germans had people, there it was Canadian military. So Cubans and the Russians. Everybody mingled. In particular, Cubans were famous for buying bicycles and shipping them back to Cuba.
俄罗斯航空公司“俄罗斯航空”仅在甘德就有超过150名机组人员和飞行计划员。甘德在当时比加拿大一些大城市要多元文化得多。英国人有自己的人，德国人有自己的人，那里有加拿大军队。还有古巴人和俄罗斯人。每个人都混在一起。特别是，古巴人以购买自行车并将其运回古巴而闻名。
The airport turned Gander into an amazingly diverse place, and beyond that, it was a portal from the town to the rest of the world. There are stories about local people with the right connections, hopping on last minute flights to Cuba and Europe and New York City just by clearing it with the captain. And maybe it was all those trips to New York that prepared the people of Gander for September 11th, 2001. As Matt just mentioned, we have a breaking new story to tell you about.
机场把甘德变成了一个非常多元化的地方，除此之外，它还是小镇通往世界其他地方的门户。有一些关于当地人利用人脉，通过与机长打招呼，搭乘最后一分钟飞往古巴、欧洲和纽约市的航班的故事。也许正是所有这些去纽约的旅行，让甘德的人们为2001年9月11日做好了准备。正如马特刚才提到的，我们有一个突发新闻要告诉你。
Apparently, a plane has just crashed into the World Trade Center here in New York City. It happened just a few moments ago, apparently. We have very little stuff in my wife said to her. She had the news on in the morning and she said, it looks like an airplane crashed in the... one of the buildings in New York. On the morning of September 11th,
显然，一架飞机刚刚撞上了纽约市的世界贸易中心。就在几分钟前发生的，显然。我妻子说她知道得很少。她早上打开新闻，她说，看起来有一架飞机撞上了……纽约的一栋大楼。9月11日的早晨，
an unprecedented decision was made to close all American airspace. Hundreds of flights were diverted to land at airports in Canada. I was only on about 10 minutes when the time manager called me and said, you better come in, we may be getting some planes. The Inter Air India 113,
做出了一个史无前例的决定，关闭所有美国领空。数百个航班被改道降落在加拿大的机场。我才上班大约10分钟，时间经理就打电话给我说，你最好过来，我们可能会接到一些飞机。印度航空113，
will we go to Toronto? There, any 113 center, a negative, you must now land at Gander, at turn right heading 3-2-0. As the planes came in one by one, the people of Gander gathered outside the airport to watch. Well, it was quite remarkable actually, because you would see airplanes, aircraft lights, you know, miles and miles and miles in the distance.
我们要去多伦多吗？这里是113中心，否定，你现在必须降落在甘德，右转航向3-2-0。当飞机一架接一架地飞进来时，甘德的人们聚集在机场外观看。嗯，这确实非常引人注目，因为你会看到飞机，飞机的灯光，你知道，在几英里之外。
It all lined up to land, right? So it was quite a remarkable scene. 38 planes and nearly 7,000 passengers ended up in Gander. They called the stranded visitors the plane people. But the plane people weren't there just for a few hours. They were there for three days and they had nothing. The passengers weren't allowed to take their luggage so they had arrived in Gander with nothing but the clothes on their backs. After each passenger was registered with the Red Cross, a loose network of
它们都排好队准备降落，对吧？所以那是一个非常引人注目的场景。38架飞机和近7,000名乘客最终降落在甘德。他们称这些滞留的游客为“飞机人”。但“飞机人”不仅仅在那里待了几个小时。他们在那里待了三天，而且一无所有。乘客不允许携带行李，所以他们到达甘德时除了身上的衣服外什么都没有。在每位乘客向红十字会登记后，一个由甘德及附近社区志愿者组成的松散网络，
volunteers from Gander and nearby communities, provided thousands of hot meals, toilet trees, and prescriptions to the plain people. Bus drivers who run strike came back to work to drive them around town. It was a job Gander was born to do. And our job here, our people came true and said, we're here, we're here to help you until you're ready to leave. and said, we're here. We're here to help you until you're ready to leave." Gander had 500 hotel rooms in 7,000 new guests.
为“飞机人”提供了数千份热餐、洗漱用品和处方药。罢工的公交车司机回来工作，开车送他们去镇上。这是甘德天生要做的工作。我们这里的工作，我们的人民挺身而出说，我们在这里，我们在这里帮助你，直到你准备好离开。甘德有500个酒店房间和7,000名新客人。
The population of the little town had nearly doubled overnight, and so the residents stepped up and took people in. And yes, there was people took people into their homes. Even though we were told not to do that because at that time, they didn't know how widespread that this terrorist attack would be. So this is the coolest question.
这个小镇的人口在一夜之间几乎翻了一番，所以居民们挺身而出，收留了人们。是的，确实有人把人们带回了家。尽管我们被告知不要那样做，因为当时他们不知道这次恐怖袭击会有多广泛。所以这是最酷的问题。
Did they have enough food? Oh God, you had nobody run to the food in Newfoundland. Some of the stranded passengers ended up forming strong bonds with their hosts. At least one marriage is reported to have come out of all this, and a bunch of friendships. One group of plain people who stayed at a high school started a scholarship for it that's now worth over a million dollars. The passengers organized all this on their flight home
他们有足够的食物吗？哦，天哪，在纽芬兰你永远不会缺食物。一些滞留的乘客最终与他们的房东建立了深厚的联系。据报道，至少有一桩婚姻由此产生，还有一堆友谊。一群住在高中的“飞机人”发起了一项奖学金，现在价值超过一百万美元。乘客们在回家的航班上组织了这一切，
after they finally got cleared to leave Gander. Even today, we still have people come back to visit people in people's homes, that's stayed here, we have people in Gander, that goes to the US. This 9-11 story is sort of famous because the Broadway musical Come From Away, in which the Gander that go to the US. This 9-11 story is sort of famous because the Broadway musical come from away in which the Gander Mayor Claude Elliott
在他们最终获准离开甘德之后。即使在今天，我们仍然有人们回来探望住在人们家里的人，那些留在这里的人，我们有甘德的人去美国。这个9-11故事之所以出名，是因为百老汇音乐剧《来自远方》，其中甘德市长克劳德·埃利奥特
is a central character. And there's just five or six of us from the community that's portrayed in that play, but we represent this whole community. Is it a good likeness or well, he's not like me. I mean, I'm beautiful, Loken, but he's not like me, but I have four on the American. He's done a pretty good job trying to imitate a new flander. They see no men's at island but an island makes a man. Especially when one comes from one like this and that. Welcome to Lurac.
是一个核心人物。社区里只有五六个人在那部戏里被描绘，但我们代表了整个社区。它像吗？嗯，他不像我。我的意思是，我很帅，但他不像我，但我有四个美国人。他模仿纽芬兰人做得很好。他们说不是岛造就了人，而是人造就了岛。特别是当一个人来自这样一个岛时。欢迎来到卢拉克。
Hello. These days the Gander Airport is pretty quiet. Do people, it's never quite as packed I guess as it once was. No. That's Luke and Jerry Cram inside the airport. We still get international traffic today, but nowhere near the extent before they had to stop somewhere to refuel. But now you got the planes that can go on without having to stop. St. John's, the capital of Newfoundland, has the island's major international airport now.
你好。这些天甘德机场相当安静。人们，我想它从来没有像以前那样拥挤。不。那是卢克和杰里·克拉姆在机场里面。我们今天仍然有国际交通，但远不及他们必须停下来加油之前的程度。但现在你有可以不停留就飞行的飞机了。纽芬兰首府圣约翰斯现在拥有岛上主要的国际机场。
And aside from a few daily flights, Gander's traffic is mostly military planes and emergency landings. But between the military base, the Air Traffic Control Center and the airport, Gander has found ways to stay afloat. A few years ago, the airport authority was thinking of tearing down the international lounge, and building something smaller and much much uglier. But there was a huge outcry from architecture enthusiasts around the world. Full disclosure, I was one of them. In the end, thanks to organizing by people like Luke, the mid-century time capsule that is the international lounge was saved.
除了少数每日航班外，甘德的交通主要是军用飞机和紧急降落。但在军事基地、空中交通管制中心和机场之间，甘德找到了维持生存的方法。几年前，机场管理局考虑拆除国际休息室，建造一些更小、更丑的东西。但来自世界各地的建筑爱好者发出了巨大的抗议。坦白说，我是其中之一。最终，多亏了像卢克这样的人的组织，作为中世纪时间胶囊的国际休息室被保留了下来。
And Jerry Kram promises it will stay that way. Mark your words. Mark my words, but I'm not always going to be around either. And so as long as Jerry Kram is around, the international lounge stands as a kind of monument to a bygone era when flying was luxurious, when you didn't have to take your shoes off to go through security. When actually there was no such thing as security. When the bar in your airport terminal was open to anyone, ticket or not. And if Sinatra cut in front of you in line, you just tell them, please. Wait your turn. What do those big numbers painted on airport runways really mean?
杰里·克拉姆承诺它会保持原样。记住我的话。记住我的话，但我也不可能永远在这里。所以只要杰里·克拉姆还在，国际休息室就作为一个纪念过去时代的纪念碑，那时飞行是奢华的，那时你不需要脱鞋通过安检。那时根本没有所谓的安检。那时机场航站楼的酒吧对任何人开放，无论是否有票。如果辛纳屈在你前面插队，你只需告诉他，请。排队等候。机场跑道上画的那些大数字到底是什么意思？
Kurt Colstead will decode them for you, Right after this. So a few years back, the Oakland International Airport changed two of its runway numbers. 27 became 28 and 29 became 30. 99 PI's own Colessted lives in beautiful downtown, Oakland, California, and he is here to explain why it was really important that they make that change. First though, you have to understand how runway numbering works. Airports around the world use this universal system and it's based off Earth's magnetic north. So basically you figure out the magnetic compass direction of the runway up to 360 degrees, and then you round that off to the nearest 10,
库尔特·科尔斯特德将在之后为你解码。几年前，奥克兰国际机场更改了两个跑道编号。27变成了28，29变成了30。99 PI自己的科尔斯特德住在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心，他在这里解释为什么他们做出这种改变非常重要。首先，你必须了解跑道编号是如何工作的。世界各地的机场都使用这种通用系统，它是基于地球的磁北。所以基本上，你算出跑道的磁罗盘方向，精确到360度，然后四舍五入到最接近的10，
and then drop the zero at the end, and then you have your number. Okay, so you end up with a set of numbers, 1 to 36 instead of 10 to 360. Right, that's it. And each runway has a complementary number, 2 that goes in the other direction, and that's, of course, 180 degrees different.
然后去掉末尾的零，你就得到了你的数字。好的，所以你最终得到了一组数字，1到36，而不是10到360。对，就是这样。每条跑道都有一个互补的数字，2，指向另一个方向，当然，那是180度之差。
So runway number 18 is the flip side of runway number 36 and so on and so forth. And if you see letters, that actually means there are multiple runways running parallel to each other. So L is for the left, R for the right. And if there's one in the middle, they use letter C for center. So by necessity, if it was 18 L, the other side would read 36R. Yeah. Okay. Okay. And that doesn't make sense.
所以跑道18是跑道36的另一面，以此类推。如果你看到字母，那实际上意味着有多个跑道平行运行。所以L代表左，R代表右。如果中间有一个，他们使用字母C代表中心。所以必然地，如果是18L，另一边就是36R。是的。好的。好的。这说不通。
Though it's not obvious to me why they'd use compass directions rather than just numbering them one, two, and three. Well, even with all the high tech stuff that guides flights these days, magnetic directions serve as a kind of backup system to help planes land in case that they go wrong. And they also make it easy for pilots at the ground to double check that they're runway and compass aligned before they take off. So they know they're in the right place doing the right thing. Right.
虽然我不明白为什么他们使用罗盘方向而不是简单地给它们编号1、2和3。嗯，即使有现在引导飞行的高科技设备，磁方向也作为一种备份系统，帮助飞机在出错时降落。它们还使地面飞行员在起飞前能够仔细检查他们的跑道和罗盘是否对齐。所以他们知道自己在正确的地方做正确的事。对。
So if all else fails, you can use a compass. But then if it's the question, why do the numbers ever change? Now, that's the really crazy part. I knew that the planet's magnetic poles reversed every few hundred thousand years or so, but there are also these smaller but significant shifts going on constantly, and we tend to think of North in terms of true North, that, you know, stable point at the top of a globe or a map, but a compass reading of magnetic North differs from one place to the next, and it moves around all the time too,
所以如果一切都失败了，你可以使用罗盘。但如果是这样，为什么数字会改变呢？现在，这是最疯狂的部分。我知道行星的磁极每几十万年左右就会反转一次，但还有这些持续不断的小而显著的偏移，我们倾向于从真北的角度考虑北，你知道，地球仪或地图顶部那个稳定的点，但磁北的罗盘读数在不同地方有所不同，而且它也一直在移动，
driven by the flows of the Earth's molten metal outer core. And when those cumulative changes are big enough, then the airports have to repaint their runways or the numbers don't make sense anymore. Right, and it can be a small amount of change, right? It could just be, it goes from point four to point six and that tips it in the other direction. Right, because it rounds, right.
由地球熔融金属外核的流动驱动。当这些累积的变化足够大时，机场就必须重新粉刷跑道，否则数字就不再有意义了。对，而且变化量可能很小，对吧？它可能只是从0.4变成0.6，这就会使它向另一个方向倾斜。对，因为它四舍五入，对吧。
And these shifts happen even faster, closer to the poles. So airports that are really far to the north or really far to the south actually have to make these changes more often. So scientists have to keep an eye on this for their own sake, because if they're traveling on a plane,
而且这些偏移在靠近极点的地方发生得更快。所以位于极北或极南的机场实际上必须更频繁地进行这些更改。所以科学家们必须为了他们自己的利益关注这一点，因为如果他们乘坐飞机旅行，
they want to make sure these things are right. Right, they do. And it turns out it's a huge project. There are magnetic monitoring stations all around the world and satellites that also help keep track. And I was actually just talking to my dad about this. He's a geophysicist. And apparently the polls may also reverse entirely again soon,
他们想确保这些事情是正确的。对，他们会的。事实证明，这是一个巨大的项目。世界各地都有磁监测站和卫星，也有助于跟踪。我实际上刚和我父亲谈过这件事。他是一位地球物理学家。显然，磁极也可能很快再次完全反转，
but it's hard to say. And when that happens, it could actually cause problems for the world's electrical grids among other things, not to mention causing an entire repainting of airport codes. That's the least of their problems. When you say soon, what do you mean by soon? Like, should I be prepping right now?
但这很难说。当这种情况发生时，它实际上可能会导致世界电网出现问题，更不用说导致机场代码的全面重新粉刷了。那是他们最不担心的问题。当你说明年时，你是什么意思？比如，我现在应该准备吗？
Well, if you look at the historical record, we're actually overdue already, but it could still be thousands of years out soon in, you know, geological time can be pretty long in terms of human time. Okay, so buy your cans of soup is what you're saying. Yeah, just a couple of cans. Well, it's good to know. Meanwhile, if you want to geek out with more about Runway Fonds and other flight related design details, you can find Kurt's article on our website, it's 99pi.org.
嗯，如果你看历史记录，我们实际上已经逾期了，但它可能还需要几千年，“很快”在，你知道，地质时间里可能在人类时间里相当长。好的，所以你的意思是买罐头汤。是的，就买几罐。嗯，很高兴知道。同时，如果你想了解更多关于跑道字体和其他飞行相关设计细节的信息，你可以在我们的网站上找到库尔特的文章，网址是99pi.org。
99% invisible was produced this week by Luke Quinton and senior producer Katie Mangle. Mixing tech production by Sriviusive Music by Sean Rial. Delaney Hall is the senior editor. Kurt Colstead is the digital director. Thrust the team is Emmett Fitzgerald Avery, Trophiman, Taren, Mazza, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 KALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row, in beautiful, downtown,
《99%隐形》本周由卢克·昆顿和高级制片人凯蒂·曼格制作。混音技术制作由斯里维苏夫负责，音乐由肖恩·里亚尔创作。德莱尼·霍尔是高级编辑。库尔特·科尔斯特德是数字总监。团队成员还有埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、艾弗里·特罗夫曼、塔伦·马扎和我罗曼·马尔斯。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的一个项目，在美丽的市中心广播街制作，
Oakland, California. 99% of visible is part of radio topia from PRX, a collective of the best, most innovative shows in all of podcasting. We are supported by our listeners, just like you. You can find 99% of visible and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars in the show at 99PI Orc, run Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. But you're always welcome over at our place at 9ipi.org. Radio Tapio.
加利福尼亚州奥克兰。99%隐形是PRX的RadioTopia的一部分，这是一个汇集了所有播客中最优秀、最具创新性节目的集合。我们得到像你一样的听众的支持。你可以在Facebook上找到《99%隐形》并加入关于节目的讨论。你可以在推特上关注我@Roman Mars，关注节目@99PI Orc，也可以在Instagram、Tumblr和Reddit上关注。但随时欢迎你来我们的网站9ipi.org。Radio Tapio。
From PRX. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
来自PRX。你 本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。